Kiana Jackson is a kid who frequently scans the room for a more exciting option than what is right in front of her. So of course she was the first to notice a regular day, freshman year, high school, when something exciting did happen.
基亚娜·杰克逊（Kiana Jackson）是个孩子，她总是环顾四周，寻找比眼前事物更令人兴奋的选择。所以，当高中一年级平凡的一天真的发生了什么令人兴奋的事情时，她自然是第一个注意到的人。
KIANA JACKSON: I remember I was sitting in lunchroom and I saw a bunch of kids that I knew for sure they did not go to our school because they were white kids and there is no white kids in our school. And then I'm a really social person, so I see these kids. I was like, "OK, they do not go here. What are they doing here? I want to find out."
基亚娜·杰克逊：我记得当时我正坐在食堂里，看到一群孩子，我敢肯定他们不是我们学校的，因为他们是白人孩子，而我们学校没有白人。我是一个非常善于社交的人，所以我看到这些孩子时心想：“好吧，他们不是这里的学生。他们来这里做什么？我想弄清楚。”
The kids were visiting from private school just up the road, part of an exchange program between the two schools that one of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, did some reporting on that ran here on our program a few months ago. When we started putting together this week's radio show, Chana thought Kiana had to be on it. Hey there, Chana.
这些孩子是从附近的一所私立学校来参观的，这是我们制片人莎娜·乔菲-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）报道的两所学校交换项目的一部分，几个月前已经在我们的节目中播出过。当我们开始筹备这周的广播节目时，莎娜认为基亚娜一定要上节目。你好啊，莎娜。
Hello.
你好。
So why did you want her for this show?
那么，你为什么想让她上这个节目呢？
I mean, partly I wanted her for this show because of this moment right here and how Kiana handled it. Kiana is super charming. She's just sheer enthusiasm. She's a Latina kid in school and she sees a bunch of kids who don't look like anyone else in the cafeteria and she is not suspicious, or shy, or mean. She is just excited. She runs toward their table.
我的意思是，部分原因是我想要她上这个节目是因为刚才提到的那个时刻，以及基亚娜处理它的方式。基亚娜非常有魅力，她简直就是热情本身。她是学校里一个拉丁裔女孩，她看到一群在食堂里看起来与众不同的孩子，她没有表现出怀疑、害羞或刻薄。她只是感到兴奋，然后直接跑向了他们的桌子。
KIANA JACKSON: So I was just like, "Oh my gosh." So I went over and I was like, "I'm going to talk to them and eat lunch with them." So I just sat there and starting to talking to them. Like, "Yeah, this is our school." It was so exciting.
基亚娜·杰克逊：所以我当时就像，“天哪。”所以我走过去说：“我要去和他们说话，和他们一起吃午饭。”于是我就坐在那里，开始和他们聊天。我说，“是的，这就是我们的学校。”这太让人兴奋了。
And then the thing that Kiana said to me was actually something she said way later at her graduation, at her high school graduation. I asked if she kept in touch with any of the kids she met in this program. Are you still in touch with anybody?
基亚娜后来对我说的其实是她在毕业典礼上说的话，是在她高中毕业典礼上。我问她是否还和她在那个项目中遇到的那些孩子保持联系。你还在和任何人联系吗？
KIANA JACKSON: I have a lot of them on Instagram and Facebook, so we're constantly commenting on pictures. "Oh my god, your prom was so nice. Your prom was so nice too." And we told them, "Oh, whenever you guys have one of your fests, let us know." And they were like, "Yeah, you guys will come to our fests for sure."
基亚娜·杰克逊：我在Instagram和Facebook上有他们很多人，所以我们经常在照片下评论。“天哪，你的毕业舞会真棒。”“你的舞会也很棒。”我们告诉他们，“嘿，你们什么时候有派对，告诉我们一声。”他们说，“好的，你们一定会来参加我们的派对的。”
Fests?
派对（fests）？
Yeah, the fests are apparently these parties that the private school kids have, and Kiana told me they'll rent out a private club in Manhattan and--
是的，这些派对显然是私立学校的孩子们举办的，基亚娜告诉我他们会租下曼哈顿的一家私人俱乐部，而且——
KIANA JACKSON: This insane party, and they're like white kid wasted. So we just want to see how it is. Yeah.
基亚娜·杰克逊：那是场疯狂的派对，他们就像白人小孩那样喝得烂醉。所以我们只是想看看是什么样的。是的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
What's "white kid wasted" mean?
什么是“白人小孩那样喝得烂醉”（white kid wasted）？
I don't know.
我不知道。
KIANA JACKSON: It's parties that we haven't experienced.
基亚娜·杰克逊：那是我们还没经历过的派对。
Kiana paused after this, thought about it more, and finally said, "I don't know. I don't know what white wasted is. That's why I want to go. I want to see what that looks like."
基亚娜在那之后停顿了一下，想了更多，最后说：“我不知道。我不知道什么是‘白人喝得烂醉’。这就是为什么我想去。我想看看那是什么样子。”
So I've thought about this moment many times since then, because it's weird, right? Kiana is a New Yorker. She grew up in New York City, where there are something like four million white people, and she had never had one as a friend and she was so curious about white kids. And she told me at graduation that she decided to go to college upstate, to a school that would have mostly white students. And a big part of that was just because she wanted something different. She still had this curiosity and she was basically going on this one woman integration program.
从那以后我多次想到这个时刻，因为这很奇怪，对吧？基亚娜是纽约人。她在纽约市长大，那里有四百万白人左右，但她从未有过一个白人朋友，她对白人孩子充满好奇。她在毕业典礼上告诉我，她决定去州北部的大学，去一所大部分学生都是白人的学校。很大程度上是因为她想要一些不同的东西。她仍然保持着这种好奇心，而且她基本上是在进行一个人的整合计划。
Which brings us to today's program. Last week, we did a program about people resisting integration at every turn. This week, we have a show of people who are running towards it, people like Kiana. And when that process goes well, the inevitable next step in an integration program, even if it's a program with just one person in it, is that people meet each other, they go through the basic "Who are you? What are you about?"
这就引出了今天的节目。上周，我们做了一个关于人们在各个环节抵制整合的节目。这周，我们有一个关于那些向整合奔跑的人的节目，像基亚娜这样的人。当这个过程进展顺利时，整合计划中不可避免的下一步，即使是一个只有一个人参与的计划，就是人们见面，经历基本的“你是谁？你是做什么的？”的过程。
And so, Chana, how is it going? How is her voluntary school desegregation plan that she invented for herself going?
那么，莎娜，进展如何？她为自己发明的自愿学校废除种族隔离计划进行得怎么样？
Mostly great. She's a year in. She just finished her freshman year, but it's been an adjustment. I mean, everything is different.
大部分都很棒。她已经一年了。她刚刚结束大一，但这需要一个适应过程。我是说，一切都不一样了。
KIANA JACKSON: Everybody is really friendly, and I didn't expect that as much, just coming from going to school in the South Bronx and just commuting all the time, everybody is not so friendly. And here, everybody will stand there for a whole minute holding the door for you until you get there. Just friendly all the time, and sometimes you don't know if it's genuine because you're not used to it.
基亚娜·杰克逊：每个人都非常友好，我没料到会这样，毕竟在南布朗克斯上学，还要一直通勤，每个人并没有那么友好。而在这里，每个人都会为了给你开门在原地站上一整分钟，直到你走到。一直都那么友好，有时你不知道这是否是真心的，因为你不习惯这样。
Wait, so you find yourself questioning if they do really want to hold the door for you?
等等，所以你发现自己在质疑他们是否真的想为你开门？
KIANA JACKSON: I know that they do, but it's weird.
基亚娜·杰克逊：我知道他们是想开，但这很奇怪。
This is probably a difference of moving from New York City to a small town but to Kiana she wonders, "Maybe they do that because they're white." Kiana went from a high school that is 1% white to a college that is 75% white, so this is a thing that happens with segregation. Once you get around people who you haven't been around before, you become just super aware of their race and your race, and is that thing happening right now because of race or is that because you're white? Is that because you're from a different part of the country or a small town? Are you just weird?
这可能与从纽约市搬到小城镇的差异有关，但对基亚娜来说，她会想，“也许他们这样做是因为他们是白人。”基亚娜从一所1%白人的高中到了一个75%白人的大学，所以这就是种族隔离所带来的后果。一旦你和以前没接触过的人在一起，你就会对他们的种族和你的种族变得超级敏感，这件事情的发生是因为种族吗？还是因为你是白人？是因为你来自国家的另一部分还是小城镇？只是因为你很奇怪吗？
Kiana told me she has two white roommates, and one of her roommates always asks her is it OK if I sleep over at my boyfriend's place tonight? Which who knows why she does that? Maybe she just thinks somebody should know where I'm sleeping. But to Kiana, it seems strange, and the first thing she goes to is, "Oh, that must be a white thing."
基亚娜告诉我她有两个白人室友，其中一个室友总是问她，今晚在男朋友家过夜可以吗？谁知道她为什么这么做？也许她只是觉得应该有人知道我在哪睡觉。但对基亚娜来说，这看起来很奇怪，她想到的第一件事就是，“噢，那一定是白人的习惯。”
And has she seen white wasted? Did she get her wish?
那她见识过那种“白人烂醉”了吗？她得偿所愿了吗？
She did. It took a little while, but she did. There was this big football game that she told me about in great detail between her school, SUNY Cortland, and their arch rival, Ithaca College. And it was her first football game. Very exciting. And after the game, kids from both schools left the stadium, flooded the streets.
她见识到了。花了一点时间，但她确实见识到了。她跟我详细描述了一场盛大的橄榄球赛，在她所在的纽约州立大学科特兰分校（SUNY Cortland）和他们的宿敌伊萨卡学院（Ithaca College）之间。那是她的第一场橄榄球赛，非常令人兴奋。比赛结束后，两所学校的孩子离开了体育场，涌向了街道。
KIANA JACKSON: Thousands of kids. Walking through the crowd, you could smell the liquor or the beer. You could smell it. That's how bad it was. There were so many people that everybody was just walking in the streets. And the Ithaca cars-- this was crazy. So Ithaca cars driving through our turf, basically. And this one kid pulled down his pants and put his ass cheeks all over the girls' car.
基亚娜·杰克逊：数千个孩子。走过人群，你能闻到酒味或啤酒味。你能闻到，就是那么严重。人太多了，每个人都在街上走。伊萨卡的汽车——这太疯狂了。所以伊萨卡的汽车开过我们的地盘，基本上是这样。然后有个小孩脱下裤子，把屁股贴在女孩们的车上。
Was the girl from Ithaca?
那个女孩是伊萨卡的吗？
KIANA JACKSON: Yeah, she was an Ithaca girl. All the girls in the car were from Ithaca, and that's why they did that.
基亚娜·杰克逊：是的，她是伊萨卡女孩。车里的所有女孩都来自伊萨卡，这就是他们那样做的原因。
Oh, OK.
噢，好吧。
KIANA JACKSON: And the girls pissed off. And they were arguing and arguing. She spit at him. And they were like, "Oh, we don't care. Blah-blah-blah."
基亚娜·杰克逊：女孩们气坏了。她们一直在争吵。她朝他吐口水。他们就说，“噢，我们不在乎，巴拉巴拉。”
Then she says everybody started pulling down their pants and putting their butts on the car.
然后她说每个人都开始脱下裤子，把屁股放在车上。
KIANA JACKSON: Yeah, to back him up like, "We don't care. Cortland." It was funny.
基亚娜·杰克逊：是的，为了支持他，就像是，“我们不在乎。科特兰。”这很有趣。
Was that what you imagined?
那和你想象的一样吗？
KIANA JACKSON: Definitely, just insane, definitely what I pictured. It lived up to the expectations. No boundaries at all, just like epic. They just act like next level crazy, like in a big mob, just do what you want. And Ithaca, they had this slogan, "Portland girls poop." And it was like--
基亚娜·杰克逊：绝对一样，就是疯狂，绝对是我想象的那样。它不负期望。根本没有界限，简直是史诗级的。他们表现得就像是那种高水平的疯狂，就像在一个大暴徒群里，只做你想做的事。而伊萨卡，他们有个口号，“波特兰（Cortland）女孩拉屎（poop）。”就像是——
Wait, "Portland girls poop?"
等等，“波特兰女孩拉屎”？
KIANA JACKSON: Yeah, that's what they-- that was their comeback--
基亚娜·杰克逊：是的，他们就是这样——那是他们的回击——
Like, P-O-O-P?
像P-O-O-P（拉屎）这样？
KIANA JACKSON: Yeah, it was really bad. We were just like, "OK, I  guess."
基亚娜·杰克逊：是的，真的很烂。我们只是觉得，“好吧，我猜是这样。”
Kiana wanted to be around white kids just because it seemed fun, and interesting, and I think she'd get to test out some theories about how crazy white kids are, how much freedom they get to be crazy. But also, this gets her something, something Kiana thinks it's worth going out of her way for.
基亚娜想和白人孩子待在一起仅仅是因为这看起来既有趣又迷人，而且我想她有机会去验证一些关于白人孩子有多疯狂的理论，看看他们有多少自由去表现得疯狂。但同时，这也为她赢得了一些东西，一些基亚娜认为值得为此付出努力的东西。
KIANA JACKSON: Some of the kids from my high school who are seniors now, they'll talk to us and be like, "Oh, what school should I go to? How do you like your school?" The advice I give to seniors is "OK, everybody's going to want to be around their same kind of people, but if you're always in the same environment, always doing the same things with the same people, you become naive or you don't really know about the world. It's better if you experience something different, because you get a view of other people. If you end up changing, if you end up becoming a different person, a lot of it is based on the community you're surrounded by, and that's reality. Your environment really makes you.
基亚娜·杰克逊：我高中里现在上大四的一些孩子，他们会跟我们聊天，问，“噢，我该去哪所学校？你喜欢你的学校吗？”我给高年级学生的建议是，“好吧，每个人都会想和自己同类的人待在一起，但如果你总是待在同一个环境里，总是和同样的人做同样的事，你会变得幼稚，或者你并不真正了解这个世界。体验一些不同的东西会更好，因为你可以获得对其他人的看法。如果你最终改变了，如果你最终成为了一个不同的人，这很大程度上取决于你周围的社区，这是现实。环境真的造就了你。”
Last week on our program, we did the first of two episodes on school desegregation, and we heard about a place that integrated schools by accident, really by accident. And the white schools in that story, they did not want integration. The governor and state legislator are actually right now trying to undo it-- this is in Missouri-- even though, as we said last week, integrating public schools has proven to be this incredibly effective way to improve education, to close the achievement gap between minority students and white students.
上周在我们的节目中，我们制作了关于学校废除种族隔离的两集节目中的第一集，我们听到了一个意外实现了学校整合的地方，真的是意外。那个故事中的白人学校，他们并不想要整合。州长和州议员现在实际上正试图撤销它——这是在密苏里州——尽管正如我们上周所说，废除公立学校种族隔离已被证明是一种极其有效的提高教育水平、缩小少数族裔学生和白人学生之间成绩差距的方法。
And today, we wanted to see what happens when integration is a plan that everybody is embracing, when people do not run away, or move, or resist, when they do what Kiana did and they seek it out, thinking that it will give them something valuable. We have the story today of an entire city trying, I mean actively trying, to integrate the schools. And we got the White House on line 1. I don't even know what that means, but it just seems like something you say. Stay with us.
而今天，我们想看看当整合成为每个人都在拥抱的计划时会发生什么，当人们不逃跑、不搬迁或不抵制时，当他们像基亚娜那样去做，并主动去寻求它，认为这会给他们带来有价值的东西时会发生什么。今天我们有整个城市都在尝试的故事，我是说积极尝试，去整合学校。我们的白宫连线正在通话中。我甚至不知道那意味着什么，但这看起来像是你会说的话。请继续收听。
Act 1, my secret public plan.
第一幕，我的秘密公共计划。
I want to read to you a report from the state commissioner of education from the state of Connecticut written in 1987. This is the kind of routine annual report sort of thing they put out, but the commissioner must have woken up feeling bold and literary the morning that he wrote this particular one, because he spoke of the tale of two Connecticuts, one wealthier, majority white Connecticut with great schools, another poor, majority black and Latino Connecticut with awful schools. And then the commissioner said that the state, in the overwhelmingly white suburbs, should promote collective responsibility for integrating the public schools.
我想读给你听一份1987年由康涅狄格州教育专员撰写的报告。这是一种他们发布的常规年度报告，但那位专员在写这份特定的报告时，一定是在感觉大胆且富有文学气息的早晨醒来的，因为他讲述了两个康涅狄格州的故事，一个是更富裕、以白人为主、拥有优质学校的康涅狄格州，另一个是贫穷、以黑人和拉丁裔为主、学校糟糕透顶的康涅狄格州。然后专员说，该州在白人占绝大多数的郊区，应该促进整合公立学校的集体责任。
He's writing this in 1987. This is the same year, the same exact year, that Boston began to walk away from busing after a decade of riots and basically civil war there over school integration. Around the country, cities were giving up on integration. There was massive white flight. This is not a time of collective responsibility.
他是在1987年写下这段话的。同一年，完全同一年，波士顿在经历了一十年的骚乱和基本上因为学校整合而导致的内战后，开始放弃校车接送。在全国范围内，城市都在放弃整合。发生了大规模的白人逃离。这不是一个集体责任的时代。
And then, even more remarkable, in at least one city in Connecticut, it happened. In Hartford, they went from 11% of their students in integrated schools to nearly half. Chana has the story of how that happened and what this rare, rare thing looks like today.
然后，更令人惊奇的是，在康涅狄格州的至少一个城市，它发生了。在哈特福德，他们的学生在整合学校中的比例从11%上升到了近一半。莎娜讲述了它是如何发生的，以及这个罕见、罕见的事情在今天看起来是什么样子。
When that report came out, it was a political scandal. It was on the front page of the newspaper just before Christmas. A state senator called for the commissioner's resignation for writing the report. The person who got Hartford to go from screaming over that report to actually doing what it called for was a man named John Brittain.
那份报告发布时，是一场政治丑闻。就在圣诞节前，它登上了报纸的头版。一位州参议员呼吁专员因撰写这份报告而辞职。让哈特福德从对那份报告大喊大叫转向真正落实其呼吁内容的人，是一个叫约翰·布里顿（John Brittain）的人。
John Brittain is a civil rights lawyer. He brings the decorum of a courtroom to all matters. John Brittain says excuse my street language to proceed an entirely dignified statement. He can elevate simple things, like phone tag.
约翰·布里顿是一位民权律师。他将法庭的礼仪带到了所有事务中。约翰·布里顿说，原谅我使用街头语言来引导一个完全庄重的声明。他可以提升简单的事情，比如电话接力。
Hello, Chana. This is John Brittain, calling you back as you requested. I'll try you later on today.
你好，莎娜。我是约翰·布里顿，按你的要求给你回电话。我稍后再联系你。
I believe you can hear his bowtie through the voicemail.
我相信你能从语音信箱中听到他的领结声。
It's Tuesday, the 14th of July. Bye-bye.
今天是7月14日，星期二。再见。
Soon after the report came out, John Brittain, with other lawyers and 17 plaintiffs, sued the state. Connecticut was a good candidate for this kind of case because of its constitution and legal precedent there. But John Brittain believed even if he won in court, they still might not actually get desegregation. He'd studied countless examples of legal victories that led to busing, which led to riots and white flight.
报告出炉后不久，约翰·布里顿与其他律师和17名原告一起起诉了该州。康涅狄格州是此类案件的合适候选者，因为它的宪法和法律先例。但约翰·布里顿认为，即使他在法庭上赢了，他们可能仍然无法真正实现废除种族隔离。他研究了无数法律胜利导致校车接送、进而导致骚乱和白人逃离的例子。
And he knew how easily people could call the whole thing a disaster and walk away. He needed to innovate. Desegregation would only stick if people chose it. He would get the courts on his side, but he needed the public even more. By the time he won, if he won, John Brittain needed the public to want to integrate. He needed to create what the report called for-- a sense of collective responsibility.
他知道人们是多么容易地把整件事称为一场灾难并走开。他需要创新。废除种族隔离只有在人们选择它时才会持久。他会争取法院的支持，但他更需要公众。到他获胜时，如果他获胜，约翰·布里顿需要公众想要整合。他需要创造报告所呼吁的东西——一种集体责任感。
So in addition to battling in the courts, he was preparing a second front, a battle that would happen for the newspapers and TV. The people he'd be bringing into court would have to do double duty. They'd have to give legal testimony and also talk to the people of Connecticut. Of course, those who could testify most credibly about the conditions in the schools were employed by the schools.
因此，除了在法庭上进行斗争，他还在准备第二条战线，一场会在报纸和电视上发生的战斗。他带到法庭的人将不得不履行双重职责。他们将不得不提供法律证词，并与康涅狄格州的民众交谈。当然，那些能够最可信地证明学校状况的人是被学校雇佣的。
And we had to ask the superintendent if he would mind using his employees to be plaintiffs in the case, and he consented.
我们不得不问负责人是否介意让他的员工成为案件的原告，他同意了。
Happily?
高兴地？
Yes, right. What superintendent do you know would let his employees be a plaintiff in a suit that's going to-- excuse my street language-- bad mouth the district in terms of its disadvantages in open court?
是的，没错。你知道哪位负责人在会允许他的员工成为诉讼的原告，去——请原谅我的街头语言——在公开法庭上抹黑本区的缺点吗？
Hartford teachers did badmouth the district. They described what it was like to teach a classroom of kids who came to school without coats in the winter. They complained about instructional time lost because nearly every child in the class suffered severe emotional issues, or dental issues, or hadn't eaten. They said their classrooms were overwhelmed by poverty.
哈特福德的老师确实抹黑了该区。他们描述了在冬天没有外套就来上学的孩子们组成的课堂里教书是什么样子。他们抱怨因班里几乎每个孩子都患有严重的情绪问题、牙齿问题或没吃饭而损失的教学时间。他们说他们的教室被贫困淹没了。
One principal described how when it rained his cafeteria would flood. A classroom ceiling had collapsed a few minutes before kids came to class. And he described how another time the roof came down, pigeon carcasses came tumbling into the building. Pigeon carcasses. The lawyers made sure to dwell on that one.
一位校长描述了下雨时他的食堂是如何被淹的。教室天花板在孩子来上课前几分钟坍塌了。他描述了另一次屋顶掉下来时，鸽子尸体滚进了楼里。鸽子尸体。律师们确保在这一点上多做文章。
The dead pigeons made the front page of the newspaper. Readers were horrified. And the people inside the schools, who already knew about this, were excited. Someone was finally talking about it. They were calling John Brittain and asking to testify. It became a bandwagon. Everyone got on.
死鸽子登上了报纸头版。读者感到震惊。而学校里已经知道这件事的人们却感到兴奋。终于有人在谈论它了。他们给约翰·布里顿打电话并要求作证。这成了一个热潮。每个人都加入了。
We had the city government, the teachers, the parents, the religious community, everybody connected, the business community, the city council begged to be a plaintiff in this suit. The Board of Education begged to be a plaintiff in the suit.
我们有市政府、教师、家长、宗教社区，所有相关人员，商业社区，市议会请求成为这起诉讼的原告。教育委员会请求成为诉讼的原告。
Wait, the Board of Education begged to be a plaintiff?
等等，教育委员会请求成为原告？
Yes, they were totally on our side. They turned over all the records, all the information, all their data.
是的，他们完全站在我们这一边。他们交出了所有的记录、所有的信息、所有的数据。
So you're suing the state--
所以你起诉了州政府——
Yes.
是的。
And the Board of Education is asking to be on your side, and not only to be on your side but to testify.
而教育委员会请求站在你这边，而且不仅是站在你这边，还要作证。
Correct.
正确。
There are only a few places in the country that have seriously committed to school integration over a long period of time. Louisville, Kentucky is one. Wake County in North Carolina. Those are the biggest. And in each case, something like this right here has occurred. A public reckoning seems to be a required step, some sort of long process by which the gap between two unequal systems is made very clear to the people who are not paying attention.
全国只有少数几个地方长期致力于学校整合。路易斯安那州路易斯维尔是一个。北卡罗来纳州的威克县。那是最大的两个。在每一个案例中，都发生了像现在这样的一些事情。一场公共清算似乎是一个必要步骤，某种漫长的过程，通过这个过程，两个不平等系统之间的差距被清楚地呈现在那些没有注意的人面前。
The people John Brittain chose to testify did not just talk about the bleak education Hartford students were getting. They talked about what they were not getting, what it meant for their students to go to school so close to kids who had great teachers, beautiful classrooms with solid ceilings, kids whose parents had cars and college degrees and ran insurance companies in town.
约翰·布里顿选择作证的人不仅仅谈论哈特福德学生正在接受的凄凉教育。他们谈论他们没有得到什么，对于他们的学生来说，在离那些拥有优秀教师、拥有坚固天花板的美丽教室的孩子，那些父母有车、有大学学位并经营保险公司的城镇里的孩子那么近的地方上学意味着什么。
One teacher testified, "I think that children can overcome the stigma of poverty. I think children can overcome the stigma of their ethnicity. But what they cannot overcome is the stigma of separation. That is like a damned spot in their being and their self-image. And that's what segregation does to children. They see themselves as apart and separate because of the language they speak, because of the color of their skin, the origin of their parents."
一位老师作证说：“我认为孩子们可以克服贫困的耻辱。我认为孩子们可以克服种族背景的耻辱。但他们无法克服的是隔离的耻辱。那就像他们本质和自我形象中一个该死的污点。这就是隔离对孩子所做的事情。他们因为所说的语言、因为皮肤的颜色、因为父母的出身而认为自己是孤立和分离的。”
John Brittain and his team won on an appeal to the state Supreme Court in 1996. It took another seven years, until 2003, for the state to settle with the plaintiffs, 14 years after he first filed the suit. When they did settle, the plan they came up with is a system where every family can choose integrated schools. But they don't have to. No parent would be required to send their kid across town. No forced busing, as it was called.
约翰·布里顿和他的团队在1996年上诉至州最高法院时胜诉。又花了七年时间，直到2003年，该州才与原告达成和解，距离他首次提起诉讼已有14年。当他们达成和解时，他们想出的计划是一个每个家庭都可以选择整合学校的系统。但他们不必这样做。没有任何家长会被要求送他们的孩子跨城上学。没有所谓的强制校车接送。
If desegregation was going to work, it would be completely voluntary. Parents would opt in. And not just the parents who read headlines during the decade long trial, but parents a whole generation later, now, parents who were kids themselves when the dead pigeons were in the newspaper. John Brittain's theory that with the help of the courts it was possible to design an integrated school system where parents continue to opt into integration over and over again, that's what's being tested right now in Hartford.
如果废除种族隔离要起作用，它必须是完全自愿的。家长会选择加入。而且不仅是那些在长达十年的审判期间阅读头条新闻的家长，而是整整一代之后的家长，现在，那些在报纸刊登死鸽子新闻时还是孩子们的家长。约翰·布里顿关于在法院帮助下设计一个整合学校系统、让家长一次又一次选择加入整合的理论，正是现在哈特福德正在测试的东西。
Everyday day at school, I get to do what I love best with friends from all over Greater Hartford.
在学校的每一天，我都能和来自大哈特福德各地的朋友一起做我最喜欢的事。
From broad, lofty vision to sales, just as John Brittain did for over a decade in court, Hartford is still every moment of every day waging an aggressive hearts and minds campaign. Only now, they aren't selling a vision. They're selling actual schools, great new schools, magnet schools that each have some special focus, like performing arts or environmental sciences. And they're selling these schools specifically to white suburban families. In large part, Hartford's integration plan hinges on getting white kids to come and integrate Hartford schools, white kids like this cheerful girl in the promotional video who has friends from all over Greater Hartford. She goes to a Hartford magnet school. Which one, you ask?
从宏大、崇高的愿景到推销，就像约翰·布里顿在法庭上做了十多年一样，哈特福德仍在每一天的每一刻进行着一场积极的心灵运动。只是现在，他们不在推销愿景。他们在推销真正的学校，很棒的新学校，每所学校都有一些特殊重点的磁力学校，比如表演艺术或环境科学。他们专门向白人郊区家庭推销这些学校。在很大程度上，哈特福德的整合计划取决于让白人孩子来整合哈特福德学校，就像宣传视频中这个有着来自大哈特福德各地朋友的开朗女孩一样的白人孩子。她去的是一所哈特福德磁力学校。你问是哪一所？
I chose Classical Magnet, where I get to learn Latin, the liberal arts, and get ready for a top college. And there are other schools for working with computers and technology, performing plays, dance, and music, engineering, running your own business, sports and medical sciences, and a lot more. I chose to go to a Harvard host magnet school and so can you.
我选择了古典磁力学校（Classical Magnet），在那里我可以学习拉丁语、文科，并为顶尖大学做准备。还有其他学校用于计算机和技术、表演剧、舞蹈和音乐、工程、经营你自己的企业、体育和医学科学，以及更多。我选择了去哈特福德的磁力学校，你也可以。
She chose this. That's on purpose. This is not forced anything. It is a multimedia blitz. There are videos, and T-shirts, and USB sticks, and bracelets, and iPhone covers. There are radio spots with HOT-937.
她选择了这个。这是故意的。这绝不是强制的。这是一次多媒体闪电战。有视频、T恤、USB存储棒、手链和iPhone外壳。有HOT-937的电台广告。
Songs on Hot 937, hot937.com.
Hot 937上的歌曲，hot937.com。
And there's a chief marketer. The woman behind the Hartford sales assault is named Enid Rey. Enid Rey considers any time of the year a good time to be selling Hartford magnet schools, even Christmas.
还有一位首席营销官。哈特福德销售攻势背后的女人叫伊妮德·雷（Enid Rey）。伊妮德·雷认为一年中的任何时候都是推销哈特福德磁力学校的好时机，甚至是圣诞节。
I'm Enid Ray. How are you? I'm doing really well.
我是伊妮德·雷。你好吗？我做得很好。
That time of year again?
又到了那个时候了？
Yes, it is that time of year. With holiday cheer comes the best gift you can give your child-- quality educational experience.
是的，又是那个时候。伴随着节日欢乐而来的是你能给孩子最好的礼物——优质的教育体验。
Education.
教育。
That's right. That's the name of the game.
没错。这就是游戏的名称。
Enid Rey is a powerhouse. She's a lawyer by training, and when she was in law school, she studied law from one incredibly inspiring teacher named John Brittain. Enid Rey was John Brittain's student in the early '90s, and now it's on her to keep John Brittain's plan moving forward.
伊妮德·雷是一位能人。她是科班出身的律师，她在法学院学习法律时，师从一位非常鼓舞人心的老师，名叫约翰·布里顿。伊妮德·雷是约翰·布里顿在90年代初的学生，现在推动约翰·布里顿的计划前进的重任落在了她的肩上。
We are always recruiting. We're always trying to get the message out about our Hartforod schools.
我们一直在招聘。我们一直在努力宣传我们的哈特福德学校。
Outside Enid's office, there's a cartoony picture of a school bus filled with multicultural kids. But I would not have been surprised to see a sign with the words "Always be closing" in that spot. Enid throws around marketing phrases like "value proposition." She's learned how to transform any question into an answer that begins with "I think what's great is." And she is so quick. She'll note, "Did you say your kid was into art? Have you heard of the Hartford Academy of the Arts? Here's a brochure and a video. I noticed you have a younger son over there. Did I mention the magnet schools provide free pre-K? Our Montessori program is very popular. Oh, and the environmental sciences school--"
伊妮德办公室外，有一张卡通画，上面是一辆载满多元文化孩子的校车。但在那个位置看到写着“永远保持成交”（Always be closing）的标志，我也不会感到惊讶。伊妮德随口说出营销术语，比如“价值主张”。她学会了如何把任何问题变成以“我认为很棒的是”开头回答。而且她反应非常快。她会指出，“你说你的孩子喜欢艺术？你听说过哈特福德艺术学院吗？这是一本小册子和一个视频。我注意到你那边有个小儿子。我提过磁力学校提供免费学前班吗？我们的蒙台梭利项目非常受欢迎。噢，还有环境科学学校——”
Has a wonderful community room, outdoor gardens, a butterfly vivarium.
拥有一个很棒的社区活动室、户外花园、蝴蝶生态园。
Also, do you work in the city?
还有，你在城里工作吗？
What a gift it is to be able to drive in with your child every day. And so one of our recruitment billboards said "Both you and your child should be working here in Hartford." That was a hook.
每天能和你的孩子一起开车过来是多么大的礼物。所以我们的一块招聘广告牌上写着“你和你的孩子都应该在哈特福德工作”。那是一个吸引点。
Enid Rey begins many days by staring at a map. Hartford students are 80% black and Hispanic. 10 miles outside the city are suburbs like Glastonbury and Avon that are 90% white. They can bus Hartford kids out of the city, and they do, but they also have to get white kids in. So a lot of mornings, Enid zeroes in on all the suburbs. Who are they reaching? Where should her recruiter go that day?
伊妮德·雷每天开始时都会盯着一张地图看。哈特福德学生中80%是黑人和拉丁裔。城外10英里处是格拉斯顿伯里（Glastonbury）和埃文（Avon）等90%是白人的郊区。他们可以把哈特福德的孩子用校车送到城外，他们也确实这么做了，但他们也必须让白人孩子进来。所以很多早晨，伊妮德都在关注所有的郊区。他们正在接触谁？她的招聘人员今天应该去哪里？
So Bloomfield has a 28% participation rate versus Simsbury, which has a 3.3% participation rate. That's where she's going.
所以布卢姆菲尔德（Bloomfield）的参与率是28%，而辛斯伯里（Simsbury）的参与率是3.3%。这就是她要去的方向。
Enid and her staff show up at baseball games in the suburbs, talk to parents about Hartford magnet schools, they leave brochures in suburban libraries, they shop at Girl Scout troop meetings, Mommy and Me groups, the YMCA. They study this market meticulously. And they consult professional marketing firms, not your little mom and pop places either, Enid tells me proudly, but people who advise companies like Apple.
伊妮德和她的员工出现在郊区的棒球比赛中，与家长谈论哈特福德磁力学校，他们在郊区图书馆留下小册子，他们在女童子军聚会、亲子小组、基督教青年会中进行推销。他们精心研究这个市场。他们咨询专业的营销公司，伊妮德骄傲地告诉我，不是那种小型家庭企业，而是像苹果公司那样咨询顾问的人。
Folks who have the technology and expertise to try to help us segment the population and hit the target, just like Pepsi, Coca-Cola, and Apple.
那些拥有技术和专业知识来帮助我们对人口进行细分并打击目标的人，就像百事可乐、可口可乐和苹果公司一样。
And just like they do in the marketing departments of large corporations, Hartford invented a scientific sounding term for the target population. They call them "reduced isolation students." That means white kids. And more recently, they included Asian kids in this mix too. They need 25%. A school that is 25% reduced isolation kids officially counts as an integrated school. That is the target of all of this effort, all the maps, the marketing firms, the promotional videos, all sales directed at one precise target.
就像在大型企业的营销部门一样，哈特福德为目标人群发明了一个听起来科学的术语。他们称他们为“减少隔离学生”。这意味着白人孩子。最近，他们也将亚裔孩子包括在这个组合中。他们需要25%。一所拥有25%减少隔离学生的学校正式算作一所整合学校。这就是所有这些努力、所有地图、营销公司、宣传视频的目标，所有的销售都指向一个精确的目标。
What is that?
那是什么？
Let me put out some food for you.
让我为你放点吃的。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I talked to lots of white suburban families around Hartford to find out what it's like to be on the receiving end of Enid's marketing blitz. Sarah and Ryan Welcome got my call, invited me over to their home, prepared a spread of food for me, including olives with toothpicks that their nine-year-old delivered to my hand, because that's just how they do. Man!
我和哈特福德周围的许多白人郊区家庭谈过，想了解一下作为伊妮德营销攻势的接收端是什么感觉。萨拉和瑞安·韦尔科姆（Sarah and Ryan Welcome）接听了我的电话，邀请我去他们家，为我准备了各种食物，包括他们的九岁孩子递到我手里的带牙签的橄榄，因为他们就是那样做的。伙计！
Get comfortable.
舒服点。
Don't worry. You're going to get pampered here, OK?
别担心。你会在这里得到呵护的，好吗？
That is amazing. The Welcomes live in a suburb across the river from Hartford-- three kids, dogs, reptiles, lots of snacks. They grew up going to their neighborhood school and figured their kids would do the same. When their oldest was about to turn five, Sarah Welcome went to an open house at the school down the road.
这太神奇了。韦尔科姆一家住在哈特福德河对岸的一个郊区——三个孩子，狗，爬行动物，很多零食。他们从小就在他们的社区学校上学，以为他们的孩子也会一样。当他们最大的孩子快五岁时，萨拉·韦尔科姆去参加了附近学校的开放日。
And I left feeling a little-- I wasn't really impressed with it. The teachers, I thought, were fine. The school seemed OK. I guess it was the parents. It was the parents. They all seemed hostile. Like, "What was the school going to do for my kid" sort of attitude. It made me cringe.
我离开时感觉有点——我对它印象并不深。老师，我觉得还可以。学校看起来还行。我想是家长。是家长。他们看起来都有敌意。就像，“学校能为我的孩子做什么”的那种态度。这让我感到不适。
I just remember the general feeling of being underwhelmed, you know?
我只记得那种平淡无奇的总感觉，你知道吗？
This is Ryan, Sarah's husband. Just to pause right here for a second to say, this is a moment Enid is obsessed with. There's always a short window where a family's thinking about school and open to new ideas. Enid studies this moment, tries to prepare the ground, and then all she can do is hope that please, please, please, one of her videos or flyers will make it to the target.
这是瑞安，萨拉的丈夫。先暂停一下，想说，这是伊妮德着迷的一个时刻。家庭总有一个短窗口期在考虑学校并对新想法持开放态度。伊妮德研究这个时刻，试图准备好基础，然后她能做的就是祈祷，求求你，求求你，求求你，她的一段视频或传单能传到目标手中。
Sarah, just at that moment, had gone back to college, Trinity College, when her son was about to start kindergarten. And very soon after the open house, she ran into a fellow mom, Audrey, at Trinity.
萨拉，就在那一刻，在她的儿子快要上幼儿园时，回到了大学，三一学院。在开放日后不久，她在三一学院遇到了另一位妈妈，奥黛丽。
I think I was working in the computer lab, writing a paper. And she had a flyer, and I remember this a little bit more vividly. She said, "You should apply to this magnet school. There's a new magnet school in Hartford that's taking suburban kids from all over. It sounds like a really great program. It's full day. It's free." And I had never heard of a magnet school before. Ryan and I didn't grow up with magnet schools. So this was a whole new concept.
我想当时我正在电脑室工作，写论文。她有一张传单，我记得这件事更生动一些。她说，“你应该申请这所磁力学校。哈特福德有一所新的磁力学校，正在接收来自各地的郊区孩子。听起来像是一个很棒的课程。它是全天的。是免费的。”我以前从未听说过磁力学校。瑞安和我不是在磁力学校长大的。所以这是一个全新的概念。
And just like that, Sarah migrated from one dataset in Enid's office to another-- parents who don't know about magnet schools to parents who do. Enid knows the next step for this group. The Welcomes were curious about this magnet thing. They read about one online, but then they looked up the address.
就这样，萨拉从伊妮德办公室的一个数据集迁移到了另一个——从不知道磁力学校的家长到知道的家长。伊妮德知道这群人的下一步。韦尔科姆一家对这个磁力学校的事很好奇。他们在网上读过一所，但后来他们查了地址。
I mean, it was in the north end of Hartford. And the north end of Hartford is not well known for amazing schools around here or anything like that. It's the scary part of Hartford. We knew the school had to wow us, because it's in the frickin' north end Hartford. You know what I mean?
我是说，它在哈特福德的北端。哈特福德的北端并不以这里有什么惊人的学校而闻名。那是哈特福德可怕的部分。我们知道学校必须让我们惊叹，因为它在哈特福德该死的北端。你知道我的意思吗？
Ryan is absolutely right. It's not necessarily the place where two young parents who grew up in Ellington would find themselves going. I never went to the north end of Hartford. I had absolutely no reason to go there.
瑞安完全正确。这不一定是两个在埃灵顿（Ellington）长大的年轻父母会去的地方。我从没去过哈特福德的北端。我完全没有理由去那里。
Enid knows she has to get parents to go there, because her target families know places like Hartford aren't white, but that's often all they know. They have never searched for housing there. They don't shop there. They don't go to church there. What they know is people like them used to live there and then they left. So the last step to get to closing, Enid has to physically get them into the neighborhoods where the schools are so they can see.
伊妮德知道她必须让家长去那里，因为她的目标家庭知道像哈特福德这样的地方不是白人居住的，但通常他们只知道这么多。他们从未在那里搜索过住房。他们不在那里购物。他们不在那里去教堂。他们知道的是像他们这样的人曾经住在那里，然后他们离开了。所以要完成成交的最后一步，伊妮德必须让他们亲自进入学校所在的社区，这样他们才能看到。
The residential neighborhoods, they look like neighborhoods in Anytown, USA, suburbia. They just happen to be in the urban core, and there happened to be a lot more black and brown people around. And some parents, they'll say, "Are they going to be the only white kid in the class?"
住宅区，它们看起来像美国任何城镇、郊区的社区。它们恰好在城市核心区，而且恰好周围有很多黑人和棕色人种。一些家长会说，“他们会成为班里唯一的白人孩子吗？”
This question is the most common one Enid gets, and the most difficult. White people do not have a lot of practice being the only one. The black family moves into the white neighborhood. The black kids much more often are bussed into the white school. Enid Ray is trying to flip a long American tradition of one way integration. The Welcome family made it to the magnet school in the scary part of Hartford, which did not seem so scary to them. They visited Breakthrough Magnet and loved it. They ended up sending all three of their children there. They were not looking for integration but they were happy to find it.
这个问题是伊妮德得到的最常见、也最困难的问题。白人对成为唯一一个并没有很多实践。黑人家庭搬进白人社区。黑人孩子更多地被用校车送到白人学校。伊妮德·雷正试图颠覆一种长期的美国单向整合传统。韦尔科姆一家到了哈特福德可怕部分的磁力学校，那对他们来说似乎并不那么可怕。他们参观了突破磁力学校（Breakthrough Magnet）并爱上了它。他们最终把三个孩子都送到了那里。他们并没有在寻找整合，但他们很高兴发现了它。
I thought that was kind of great. It's just not how I grew up. Honestly, there were maybe, what? Two black kids in a high school?
我觉得那挺棒的。只是我不是那样长大的。说实话，那里也许有，什么？高中里有两个黑人孩子？
Yeah, I would say.
是的，我会这么说。
This is how integration works in Hartford. Sometimes, white families are happy to see it, but it's not usually why they show up. Their neighborhood school is often pretty good but they were looking because their kid was bullied, or there was too much standardized testing, or the other parents seemed annoying. Enid, who is selling them on magnet schools, which exist to promote integration, also does not mention integration. The long history of segregated schooling doesn't come up. The current reality of segregated housing is irrelevant . No one here is being moved by a sense of collective responsibility. It is as if John Brittain never happened.
这就是整合在哈特福德的运作方式。有时，白人家庭很高兴看到它，但这通常不是他们出现的原因。他们的社区学校通常相当不错，但他们寻找是因为他们的孩子被欺负了，或者有太多的标准化考试，或者其他家长看起来很烦人。伊妮德，正在向他们推销磁力学校，即存在以促进整合，也没有提到整合。种族隔离学校的悠久历史没有被提及。种族隔离住房的现状无关紧要。这里没有人被一种集体责任感所触动。就好像约翰·布里顿从未发生过一样。
Instead, the experience Enid is curating is for comfort. All the detail she considers, like making sure there are white kids in the brochures, or if parents do tour a school, Enid does her best to have their child shadow a white student. That way they can see they won't be the only one.
相反，伊妮德正在策划的体验是关于舒适的。她考虑的所有细节，比如确保小册子里有白人孩子，或者如果家长参观学校，伊妮德会尽力让他们的孩子跟随一名白人学生。这样他们就能看到他们不会是唯一的一个。
If it was just we're marketing and all there are, are black and brown families, that person's not going to see themselves reflected.
如果这仅仅是我们营销，而全部都是黑人和棕色家庭，那个人就不会看到自己的反映。
But that's so ironic that you're marketing a desegregation program by showing people of the same race that other people of the same race will be there too.
但这太讽刺了，你通过向人们展示同一族裔的人也会在那里，来推销一个废除种族隔离计划。
Right, because they need to know that it is about all of us. So we encourage families to come and visit us and be surprised.
是的，因为他们需要知道这是关于我们所有人的。所以我们鼓励家庭来拜访我们并感到惊讶。
This is our vivarium, where we grow plants and stuff.
这是我们的生态园，我们种植植物之类的地方。
The butterfly vivarium is in the Environmental Sciences Magnet School at Mary Hooker. Keegan Miller's a sixth grader there, a white suburban kid with a demanding hairdo. Keegan was supposed to show an interested suburban student around his school but first I got a personal tour.
蝴蝶生态园在玛丽·胡克环境科学磁力学校（Mary Hooker Environmental Sciences Magnet School）。基冈·米勒（Keegan Miller）是那里的一名六年级学生，一个有着考究发型的白人郊区小孩。基冈本来要带一名感兴趣的郊区学生参观他的学校，但首先我得到了一个个人导览。
So this is the aquatics lab.
所以这是水生实验室。
Wow.
哇。
Currently, the sixth grade is raising baby trout. And that LEGO item right there, I built that. It's an automatic feeder.
目前，六年级正在养小鳟鱼。那个乐高物品就在那儿，我造的。那是自动喂食器。
It feeds the trout?
它喂鳟鱼？
Yes, every five hours.
是的，每五小时一次。
Keegan tells me he built the feeder in the LEGO lab upstairs. That's Keegan's favorite class, LEGO lab. He also made a 3D insect viewer, but that's in the greenhouse. Along our tour, happy looking kid see me with my microphone and stop me to tell me that it's true. They are happy.
基冈告诉我他在楼上的乐高实验室造了这个喂食器。那是基冈最喜欢的课，乐高实验室。他还制作了一个3D昆虫观察器，但在温室里。在我们的参观过程中，看起来很开心的孩子带着我的麦克风拦住我，告诉我这是真的。他们很开心。
I'm Vaishu. And I've been in this school for five years. I love it.
我是Vaishu。我在这所学校已经五年了。我爱它。
I really, really like this school.
我真的、真的很喜欢这所学校。
ALLIE: I'm Allie and I really, really like this school because--
ALLIE：我是Allie，我真的、真的很喜欢这所学校，因为——
The hundreds of millions of dollars it took to transform this school and other magnet schools in Hartford came from John Brittain's lawsuit. . That money built the atrium, with the pond in the middle of it, the angled glass that's all over the place, the aquatics lab.
将这所学校和其他哈特福德磁力学校改造成这样所花费的数亿美元来自约翰·布里顿的诉讼。那笔钱建造了中庭，中间有池塘，到处都是倾斜的玻璃，水生实验室。
I think there's a class in the planetarium. I think they may be watching.
我想天文馆里有一节课。我想他们可能在看。
Where's the planetarium?
天文馆在哪里？
This is the planetarium. Oh, there's nobody in there.
这就是天文馆。噢，里面没有人。
This is a planetarium?
这是一个天文馆？
Yeah, the lights don't want to work with me.
是的，灯光不想和我合作。
Oh my god.
噢，天哪。
He turns on the stars.
他打开了星星。
You could look at space from here. It's really cool. All the stars. It's like a 360 view.
你可以从这里看太空。这真的很酷。所有的星星。就像一个360度视图。
Whoa and you can just come and look at what space looks like any time you want?
哇，你随时想看太空的样子就可以来看吗？
Not anytime you want.
不是随时想看就可以。
Because that would be ridiculous. When you drive around suburban Hartford now, occasionally you'll see a sign on someone's lawn that says "I heart magnets." Neighbors will ask, "Hey, where does your kid go on the bus every morning?" The few-minute conversation that follows is the most powerful marketing tool available. It's what Enid or any marketer dreams of-- a conversation where one parent goes to another, "Oh, I think I've heard of that place. Does she like it? Is it safe?" Neighbor to neighbor, white person to white person. It is the same potent tool that three decades ago helped create segregated neighborhoods, repurposed to do the exact opposite.
因为那将是荒谬的。当你现在开车在郊区哈特福德转悠时，偶尔你会看到有人草坪上的标志写着“我爱磁力学校”。邻居会问，“嘿，你的孩子每天早上坐校车去哪儿？”随后的几分钟对话是目前最强大的营销工具。这就是伊妮德或任何营销人员梦想的东西——一个家长对另一个家长说，“噢，我想我听说过那个地方。她喜欢吗？安全吗？”邻里对邻里，白人对白人。这是三年前帮助建立种族隔离社区的同一个强有力工具，被重新利用去做完全相反的事情。
Of lot of the parents I talked to didn't know about the lawsuit or even that they were part of an integration plan. But they were like Ryan and Sarah Welcome. They considered the fact that their kid was in a diverse school a bonus. It wasn't on the top of the list but it was something they liked. "Well-rounded" was a phrase I heard a lot. One dad told me, "You won't believe how often my kid comes home and looks something up he heard from a friend. He's so excited by how different everyone is." And another mom told me, "I think it just gives them a deeper understanding of the world around them, which is what you hope happens in school."
我和很多家长谈过，他们不知道诉讼，甚至不知道他们是整合计划的一部分。但他们就像瑞安和萨拉·韦尔科姆。他们认为他们的孩子在多元化的学校是一个加分项。这不是名单上的第一位，但这是他们喜欢的东西。“全面发展”是我经常听到的一个词。一位父亲告诉我，“你不会相信我的孩子回家时有多少次会去查他从朋友那里听到的东西。他对每个人都有多不同感到如此兴奋。”另一位妈妈告诉我，“我想这只是给了他们对周围世界更深刻的理解，这正是你希望在学校发生的事情。”
Often, in these conversations, parents also mentioned, like Sarah did, how different this was from their own experience in school as kids. Sarah and Ryan grew up in a small, white, farming community in Connecticut, not far from Hartford. She says when she was a teenager, her high school visited a school near the city for a day, and she remembers it seemed like another world.
通常，在这些对话中，家长们也会提到，就像萨拉所做的那样，这与他们小时候在学校的经历有多么不同。萨拉和瑞安在一个离哈特福德不远、白人为主的康涅狄格农业小社区长大。她说当她十几岁时，她的高中有一天参观了城市附近的一所学校，她记得这看起来像另一个世界。
To us, it felt like a massive, huge high school with lots of black kids and possibly Puerto Rican kids. I remember it being scary. I remember some of us feeling scared. And that's weird. And now that I think about it, that sounds so stupid-- you know-- and racist, and awful, and embarrassing. I feel ashamed that I ever felt that way.
对我们来说，感觉像是一所巨大的、超大的高中，有很多黑人孩子和可能的波多黎各孩子。我记得这很吓人。我记得我们中的一些人感到害怕。这很奇怪。现在当我想到它时，这听起来太愚蠢了——你知道——而且种族主义、可怕、令人尴尬。我为我曾经有那种感觉感到羞耻。
But she says her kids probably won't share her ignorance. They have black friends and Puerto Rican friends and Hindu friends. They're learning how to interact, and play, and fight, and resolve fights with lots of different kinds of people. Again, bonus.
但她说她的孩子可能不会分享她的无知。他们有黑人朋友、波多黎各朋友和印度教朋友。他们正在学习如何与许多不同种类的人互动、玩耍、争吵和解决争吵。再次强调，加分项。
It came to me in a very happenstance way. If I had never gone to Trinity College and didn't meet Audrey, it may have never happened.
我以一种非常偶然的方式来到这里。如果我从未去过三一学院，也没有遇到奥黛丽，这可能永远不会发生。
The list of things that went into Sarah arriving at that moment with Audrey is so much longer than she knows, which is part of the plan. Sarah is not supposed to be able to see the enormous machinery working to make that moment possible, the years of planning, of litigation, the bussing contracts and inter-district agreements, and the maps on Enid's wall, all that is kept backstage so that what's onstage looks easy, so that Sarah can experience that exact feeling of happening into a cool thing.
萨拉到达与奥黛丽那个时刻的事情清单比她知道的长得多，这是计划的一部分。萨拉不应该能够看到巨大的机器在工作以使那一刻成为可能，多年的规划、诉讼、校车合同和学区间的协议，以及伊妮德墙上的地图，所有这些都被保持在后台，以便台前的东西看起来很容易，以便萨拉能够体验到偶然发现一个酷东西的那种精确感觉。
This strategy is working. This is how Hartford went from having 11% of Hartford kids in integrated schools in 2007 to almost half now. Unlike Baltimore, Chicago, Detroit, Philadelphia, Los Angeles, Hartford has given white families a way to choose integration. And many of them are choosing it. And those families, those are the people Enid needs.
这个策略正在奏效。这就是哈特福德在2007年哈特福德孩子在整合学校的比例为11%，到现在近一半的原因。与巴尔的摩、芝加哥、底特律、费城、洛杉矶不同，哈特福德给白人家庭提供了一种选择整合的方式。他们中的许多人正在选择它。而那些家庭，那些就是伊妮德需要的人。
Right, people who we need. And we desperately need some of those families.
没错，我们需要的那些人。我们非常需要那些家庭。
Hartford desperately needs those families because despite all the success the city has had, they are facing a potential crisis. The last couple years, Hartford has barely been making its quota of reduced isolation students for its magnet schools, the required number of white kids, and now also Asian kids to call a school integrated. And if they stop meeting the quota, they don't get money. If they don't get money, they can't create new schools to reach more kids. In fact, the magnet schools that already exist will lose the money that makes them such great schools. The stars will stop shining in the planetarium.
哈特福德非常需要这些家庭，因为尽管这个城市取得了所有的成功，他们正面临一场潜在的危机。过去几年，哈特福德几乎没有达到其磁力学校减少隔离学生的配额，即白人孩子所需的数量，现在也包括亚裔孩子，以称一所学校为整合学校。如果他们不再达到配额，他们就得不到钱。如果他们得不到钱，他们就无法创造新学校来覆盖更多的孩子。事实上，已经存在的磁力学校将失去使它们成为如此优秀学校的钱。星星将停止在天文馆闪烁。
Enid and her team have theories about why they've stalled, including one theory Enid does not like to think about, and that is that they've maxed out. They may have already reached all the white families who were dissatisfied with their neighborhood schools, which, on the whole, are pretty good schools.
伊妮德和她的团队有关于他们为什么停滞不前的理论，包括一个伊妮德不想去想的理论，那就是他们已经达到了极限。他们可能已经覆盖了所有对社区学校不满意的白人家庭，这些学校总体上是相当不错的学校。
They may have already gotten all the white families who'd be willing to drive to the scary part of Hartford for an open house, and then who'd be willing to do what so few white families have done before them, to be the ones to bring the integration. Maybe everyone who was going to tell their neighbor about their great magnet school in the city already has. Market saturation. If that is what's making it so hard to meet the quota recently, that could blow up the plan.
他们可能已经得到了所有愿意为了开放日开车去哈特福德可怕部分的白人家庭，然后愿意做很少白人家庭以前做过的事情，成为带来整合的人。也许每个打算告诉邻居关于他们在城里伟大的磁力学校的人都已经说过了。市场饱和。如果这就是最近让配额难以达到的原因，那可能会毁掉这个计划。
Enid's office is on the third floor of a state building. And on that side of the hall, where she is, it's all about wooing suburban families and offering treats and butterflies. Across the hall is a place called The Regional School Choice Office.
伊妮德的办公室在州政府大楼的三楼。在大厅的那一边，她所在的地方，全是关于讨好郊区家庭，提供款待和蝴蝶。大厅对面是一个叫地区学校选择办公室（The Regional School Choice Office）的地方。
Hey, ladies.
嘿，女士们。
The Regional School Choice Office is a tiny cluster of cubicles crowded with women on headsets answering the phones. All available space is covered in forms, and brochures, and paperwork. Anybody can call or visit the office, but mostly this side of the hall is not for the suburban parents. It's for the city parents, the Hartford families. There's a lottery for a Hartford magnet school seat, and last fall, more than 4,000 Hartford students did not win that lottery. These were families who, for the most part, don't get courted. They get paperwork. And the majority of them get wait-listed.
地区学校选择办公室是一个很小的隔间群，挤满了戴着耳机接听电话的女性。所有可用空间都覆盖着表格、小册子和文书工作。任何人都可以打电话或访问该办公室，但这一边的大厅大多不是为郊区家长准备的。它是为城市家长，即哈特福德家庭准备的。有一个哈特福德磁力学校席位的抽奖，去年秋天，超过4000名哈特福德学生没有赢得那个抽奖。这些家庭，在大多数情况下，没有得到追求。他们得到的是文书工作。而他们中的大多数人被列入候补名单。
Now they're calling a lot for their wait-list numbers. So now they are at the point of really wanting the seat. When they don't realize we get a lot more applications than we do seats, parents call every day to see if their numbers have moved, and if they're still going to have that chance.
现在他们经常打电话询问他们的候补号码。所以现在他们处于非常想要那个席位的地步。当他们没意识到我们收到的申请比席位多得多时，家长每天都打电话看他们的号码是否移动了，以及他们是否还有那个机会。
So you're dealing with a lot of frustrated parents sometimes.
所以你有时要处理很多沮丧的家长。
Sometimes? All the time, all the time.
有时？一直，一直。
Hartford parents right now are frustrated for the exact same reason parents were frustrated with Hartford schools in the 1980s when John Brittain sued-- their schools are inferior. Magnet school kids do great. They go to integrated schools and 80% of them pass state tests. Hartford public school kids go to segregated schools. Less than 40% of them pass state tests.
哈特福德的家长现在感到沮丧的原因与20世纪80年代约翰·布里顿起诉时家长对哈特福德学校感到沮丧的原因完全相同——他们的学校是劣质的。磁力学校的孩子表现很好。他们去整合学校，80%通过了州考试。哈特福德公立学校的孩子去种族隔离学校。不到40%通过了州考试。
Magnet school kids can explore space on the first floor of their school. Hartford public school buildings have gotten better but they're not like that. For the 50% of Hartford families who can't get their kids into the beautiful, integrated magnet schools, things are exactly the same as they've always been, only worse because now there's a school with a planetarium down the block that they can't get into.
磁力学校的孩子可以在他们学校的一楼探索太空。哈特福德公立学校的建筑变得更好了，但它们不像那样。对于50%无法让孩子进入美丽、整合的磁力学校的哈特福德家庭来说，事情和过去一模一样，甚至更糟，因为现在街区那边有一所有天文馆的学校，他们进不去。
That school with the planetarium, by the way, the Environmental Sciences Magnet, it used to just be Mary Hooker Elementary before integration. It was just a regular public school. And back when it was a regular public school, it was almost entirely Latino. There was no planetarium, no LEGO lab, or butterfly vivarium. Those came when it went magnet. Those came with the white students.
顺便说一句，那所有天文馆的学校，环境科学磁力学校，在整合之前它只是玛丽·胡克小学。它只是一所普通的公立学校。当它是一所普通公立学校时，它几乎完全是拉丁裔的。没有天文馆，没有乐高实验室，或蝴蝶生态园。那些是在它变成磁力学校时出现的。那些是随着白人学生出现的。
The argument against separate but equal was never that separate schools couldn't be equal, theoretically, just that it never, ever happens. One of the early civil rights leaders, Charles Thompson, wrote, "The separate school or separate anything with equal facilities is a fiction."
反对隔离但平等的论点从来不是说隔离学校在理论上不能平等，只是说它从来、从来没有发生过。早期的民权领袖之一查尔斯·汤普森（Charles Thompson）写道：“隔离的学校或任何带有平等设施的隔离都是虚构的。”
Hartford believed that when it set up its program, that the only way to make the schools better for nonwhite kids was to bring in white kids. And now here they are, stuck in a very uncomfortable place. They don't have equal schools for everybody yet. Instead, what they have are excellent schools that half the city's population, almost all of them black and Hispanic, cannot access.
哈特福德在设立其计划时相信这一点，即让非白人孩子的学校变得更好的唯一方法是引入白人孩子。现在他们在这里，陷入了一个非常不舒服的地方。他们还没有为每个人提供平等的学校。相反，他们拥有的是优秀的学校，城市一半的人口，几乎都是黑人和西班牙裔，无法进入。
They have spent decades working so hard to replace a separate but equal system, and they're still having to live with one. Which brings us back to Enid Rey. Her job is to get the city unstuck. Every day, she is consumed with wooing, courting, encouraging white families. And at night, Enid goes home to her neighborhood in Hartford. She's Puerto Rican. She grew up in Hartford. She still lives here.
他们花了数十年时间努力取代隔离但平等的系统，他们仍然不得不与之共存。这就把我们带回了伊妮德·雷。她的工作是让这个城市摆脱困境。每一天，她都沉浸在讨好、追求、鼓励白人家庭中。而在晚上，伊妮德回到她在哈特福德的社区。她是波多黎各人。她在哈特福德长大。她仍然住在这里。
So this is a bizarre job for her, assuring white suburban families, "Don't worry. It's safe. There'll be other white kids here." I'm just curious what it's like for you to be in the position of being the conduit for all of those conversations?
所以这对她来说是一份奇怪的工作，向白人郊区家庭保证，“别担心。很安全。这里会有其他白人孩子。”我只是很好奇你处于作为所有这些对话的渠道的位置是什么感觉？
It sucks! It's very hard and it's very emotional. I mean, it's really tough.
太糟了！这非常困难，而且非常情绪化。我的意思是，这真的很艰难。
Enid grabbed my microphone as she said this, which totally surprised me, because she had spent hours trying to sell me on Hartford's great schools. But she wanted to make sure I understood just how brutal this job can be. At home, Enid's neighbors nag her. "How come my son can't get into that magnet school? Can't you help my first grader out of his failing school?" She says her husband sets a timer when she's grocery shopping. He sets a timer and watches it. And he will save her if she is trapped in a conversation with an upset parent, a parent who Enid can almost always sympathize with, because she knows they're trapped with bad options, in exactly the same way Enid's family was when she was growing up. Meanwhile--
伊妮德在说这话时抢走了我的麦克风，这完全让我感到惊讶，因为她花了几小时试图向我推销哈特福德优秀的学校。但她想确保我理解这份工作可能会有多么残酷。在家时，伊妮德的邻居唠叨她。“为什么我的儿子进不去那所磁力学校？你不能帮我的幼儿园一年级学生脱离他那所失败的学校吗？”她说她丈夫在她去杂货店购物时设置了一个计时器。他设置一个计时器并盯着它。如果她被困在与一位不安的家长的谈话中，他会救她，这位家长伊妮德几乎总是能产生共鸣，因为她知道他们被困在糟糕的选择中，就像伊妮德在长大时家庭所面临的一模一样。同时——
Some of our suburban families come because they get free preschool. I mean, think about it. They could afford to pay, but if you get a magnet seat, you're going to get free preschool. And I think a factor is that in the back of their head is also, "If it doesn't work, I'll just go back to my neighborhood school." Right? "If this whole thing just doesn't work out for my child or I don't feel comfortable, I always have another option." Right?
我们的一些郊区家庭来是因为他们得到免费学前班。我的意思是，想一想。他们负担得起，但如果你得到一个磁力席位，你就会得到免费学前班。我认为一个因素是，在他们的潜意识里还有，“如果这不起作用，我就会回到我的社区学校。”对吧？“如果整件事对我的孩子不起作用或者我感觉不舒服，我总有另一个选择。”对吧？
It's an experiment.
这是一个实验。
Right. And they can experiment, quite frankly. Not so much the case for our Hartford resident families. This is it. This is their shot at quality.
没错。而且他们可以实验，坦率地说。哈特福德的居民家庭情况就不是这样。这就是全部。这是他们获得质量的机会。
Of course, they'd get another shot if more Hartford kids could be bussed to the suburbs. But here's the problem with that. Integration is not just voluntary for white families who choose to come into the city, to the magnet schools. The suburban school districts also get to choose. They get to choose how many city children they'll allow to be bused in to their schools. And they don't allow in so many.
当然，如果更多的哈特福德孩子能被用校车送到郊区，他们就会有另一个机会。但这里有一个问题。整合不仅对选择进入城市、到磁力学校的白人家庭是自愿的。郊区学区也有选择权。他们可以决定他们允许多少城市孩子被用校车送到他们的学校。而且他们允许的不多。
The last superintendent of Hartford public schools wanted to drop the whole integration thing altogether, just focus on Hartford students. Enid says she can totally understand that position. John Brittain, the man who put this whole thing in motion, concedes that 50% of Hartford kids still in inferior schools, that's bad. But he says they are not stalled. They're just in the middle.
上一任哈特福德公立学校负责人想完全放弃整个整合的事情，只专注于哈特福德学生。伊妮德说她完全理解那个立场。约翰·布里顿，那个开启这一切的人，承认50%的哈特福德孩子仍然在劣质学校中，那很糟糕。但他表示他们并没有停滞。他们只是在中间。
John Brittain believes they're on a path that will get to 100% of Hartford kids in integrated magnet schools. Here's how he imagines they'll get there. By the time this current generation of kids is grown, white people will no longer be the majority in this country. And then white parents will want their kids in integrated schools, because that will give them the skills to thrive and compete in a more diverse society.
约翰·布里顿相信他们正走在一条能让100%哈特福德孩子进入整合磁力学校的道路上。这是他想象他们如何到达那里的方式。当这一代孩子长大时，白人将不再是这个国家的多数。然后白人家长会想要他们的孩子进入整合学校，因为那将给予他们在更多元化的社会中茁壮成长和竞争的技能。
Whites will perceive in their self-interests that it's important for their children to grow up in an integrated setting.
白人会意识到从他们自身的利益出发，让他们的孩子在一个整合的环境中长大是很重要的。
In other words, the pitch will shift from one that completely ignores the diversity of the schools and is instead focused on how much your kid will get to one that sells the diversity of the schools and is still focused on how much your kid will get. I pointed out that there are plenty of examples of places where a white minority has not chosen to embrace diversity, but John Brittain stuck to his guns.
换句话说，推销方式将从完全忽略学校多样性并专注于你的孩子会得到多少，转向一种推销学校多样性并仍然专注于你的孩子会得到多少的方式。我指出有许多地方白人少数群体没有选择拥抱多样性的例子，但约翰·布里顿坚持自己的观点。
I do think it's going to happen. It probably won't happen in my lifetime at age 70, but I think we're on the road to that trajectory.
我确实认为它会发生。这可能不会在我70岁的一生中发生，但我认为我们正在走在那条轨道上。
Ryan Welcome, the suburban dad who sent all three of his kids to the magnet school in the city, told me when they visited that school he felt like he won the lottery. Ryan didn't mean anything by this, just that the school was lovely. But of course, that is quite literally true. His family won the lottery. John Britain's plan to scale up his vision of a completely integrated Hartford preserves that feeling, that you lucked out. Because that is what works, and it's also what's true.
瑞安·韦尔科姆，那位把三个孩子都送到城里磁力学校的郊区爸爸，告诉我当他们参观那所学校时，他感觉像赢了彩票。瑞安并不意味什么，只是说学校很可爱。但当然，那在字面上确实是真的。他的家庭赢了彩票。约翰·布里顿扩大其完全整合哈特福德愿景的计划保留了那种你很幸运的感觉。因为那是奏效的，而且那也是事实。
Chana Joffe-Walt. There's a great book that tells the story of Hartford's integration plan by Susan Eden called The Children in Room E4. Coming up, the Obama administration admires what's being done in Hartford. They say they are for more integration. They don't seem to be pushing it. We ask why from the man at the top. Well, not the very top-- the Secretary of Education, that's the one we talked to. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
莎娜·乔菲-沃尔特。有一本很棒的书讲述了哈特福德整合计划的故事，由苏珊·伊甸（Susan Eden）所著，叫《E4室里的孩子》（The Children in Room E4）。接下来，奥巴马政府赞赏在哈特福德所做的事情。他们说他们支持更多的整合。他们似乎并没有在推动它。我们询问原因，从最高层的人那里。嗯，不是最高层——教育部部长，那才是我们交谈的对象。那将在稍后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台，当我们的节目继续时。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our program, The Problem We All Live With Part Two. This is our second show about school integration. As we said last week, it's amazingly effective at bringing up test scores and closing the achievement gap, but it's never really talked about as a serious option for fixing schools. So we thought, "OK, let's talk about it here." We have arrived at Act 2 of our program. Act 2, What's it All About, Arne?
这是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天在我们的节目中，我们都生活在的问题（The Problem We All Live With）第二部分。这是我们关于学校整合的第二个节目。正如我们上周所说，它在提高考试成绩和缩小成绩差距方面非常有效，但它从未被真正作为修复学校的严肃选择来讨论。所以我们想，“好吧，让我们在这里讨论一下。”我们已经到达了我们节目的第二幕。第二幕，这是关于什么的，阿恩（Arne）？
There was this moment a few years ago that was small but telling when a woman named Pat Todd gave a speech at a conference in DC. She's from one of the other very few places that runs a regional school integration program, Louisville, Kentucky, Jefferson County. They've been doing this since the 1970s. They've never abandon this, even though, she says in her speech, it doesn't get easier. It never does. It's been decades of resistance, court cases, indifference, right up to today. And she said in her speech there was one thing that would make this a whole lot easier for her. She brought it up very politely.
几年前有一小刻但很说明问题的时候，一位叫帕特·托德（Pat Todd）的女士在华盛顿特区的一次会议上发表了演讲。她来自少数几个运行区域学校整合计划的地方之一，路易斯安那州路易斯维尔，杰斐逊县。他们从20世纪70年代就开始这样做了。他们从未放弃过这一点，尽管，她在演讲中说，它并没有变得更容易。它从来没有。这是几十年的抵制、法庭案件、冷漠，一直持续到今天。她在演讲中说，有一件事会让这对她来说变得容易得多。她非常有礼貌地提出了这个问题。
I bring from Jefferson County, Kentucky an invitation.
我从肯塔基州杰斐逊县带来了一个邀请。
Her invitation was basically saying, "Hey, bigwigs, Obama administration, Washington, we need you. We need you out front on this. We need the big guns. Speak up. We cannot hear you down here.
她的邀请基本上是在说，“嘿，大人物们，奥巴马政府，华盛顿，我们需要你们。我们需要你们站在前线。我们需要重炮。大声说出来。我们在下面听不到你们的声音。”
What I really need and what my community really needs right now is for someone besides the local educators to be talking about the importance of diversity in public education, people with stature and credibility well beyond the local level.
我真正需要的是，我的社区现在真正需要的是，除了当地教育工作者之外，有人在谈论多样性在公共教育中的重要性，具有超越地方水平的地位和可信度的人。
This week, Chana Joffe-Walt and Nikole Hannah Jones, who reported last week's episode, talked to the Secretary of Education Arne Duncan about the fact that the administration does not seem to be pushing this as a policy. Hi, guys.
本周，莎娜·乔菲-沃尔特和尼可·汉纳·琼斯（Nikole Hannah Jones），报道了上周节目的记者，与教育部部长阿恩·邓肯（Arne Duncan）谈论了政府似乎没有将此作为政策推动的事实。嗨，伙计们。
Hello.
你好。
NIKOLE HANNAH JONES: Hi.
尼可·汉纳·琼斯：嗨。
So what did he say?
那么他说了什么？
NIKOLE HANNAH JONES: What Secretary Duncan said is, "Of course the administration supports integration. Integration is a good thing."
尼可·汉纳·琼斯：邓肯部长所说的是，“当然政府支持整合。整合是一件好事。”
So it's something that's obviously been very important to many of us for many, many years, long before we ever came to Washington. We have not done enough.
所以这显然对我们许多人来说多年来一直非常重要，远在我们来到华盛顿之前。我们做得还不够。
So he supports integration. He said lots of people in the administration also support integration and confirmed something we heard from other sources that this was really on the table, especially during the transition into the Obama administration, that lots of people were talking about integration and trying to figure out how to make it into formal policy.
所以他支持整合。他说政府中的许多人也支持整合，并证实了我们从其他来源听到的事情，即这确实在讨论桌上，特别是在向奥巴马政府过渡期间，许多人正在讨论整合并试图弄清楚如何将其转化为正式政策。
Mhm.
嗯。
And then very quickly they got an opportunity, because they came out with the Race to the Top.
然后他们很快得到了一个机会，因为他们提出了《力争上游》（Race to the Top）。
Yeah, just remind us what that was.
是的，提醒一下我们那是什么。
So Race to the Top was the Obama administration's first big education initiative, where they really set their agenda. It was money from the Stimulus during the recession. And it was basically $4 billion set aside to encourage states to move in the direction that the Obama administration wanted them to. So if they increased teacher accountability, did stuff with turnaround schools, expanded Common Core, basically all these things that I'm saying. If you've heard any of these terms, it's because of Race to the Top.
所以《力争上游》是奥巴马政府的第一个大教育倡议，他们真正设定了他们的议程。那是经济衰退期间来自刺激计划的钱。基本上40亿美元被留出来鼓励各州朝着奥巴马政府希望它们去的方向发展。所以如果它们提高了教师问责制，做了有关转型学校的事情，扩大了通用核心（Common Core），基本上所有我所说的这些东西。如果你听说过这些术语中的任何一个，那都是因为《力争上游》。
Right.
对。
30 states changed their laws. And Race to the Top would have been a pretty perfect place to put integration because they didn't make anybody do anything--
30个州改变了它们的法律。而《力争上游》本将是一个非常完美的地方来放入整合，因为他们没有强迫任何人做任何事——
They didn't force it. It wasn't forced integration.
他们没有强迫它。这不是强制整合。
Right, it wasn't forced integration. It was incentives. So it was, "If you want to apply, you can, and you can move in this direction that we want you to."
没错，这不是强制整合。它是激励措施。所以它意味着，“如果你想申请，你可以，你可以朝着我们希望你去的方向发展。”
OK, so you have a pro-integration administration. They're trying to incentivize states to do all sorts of things. Did they include it?
好吧，所以你有一个支持整合的政府。他们正试图激励各州做各种事情。他们包括了它吗？
No. It was not in there. And actually, John Brittain, who had been meeting with the administration during the transition, expected it to. And he went to read about the Race to the Top program in the Federal Register, which outlines what the Race to the Top was going to do, and he read every page.
没有。它不在里面。而且事实上，曾在过渡期间与政府会面的约翰·布里顿，期望它会包含。他去阅读《联邦公报》（Federal Register）中的《力争上游》计划，该报概述了《力争上游》将要做什么，他阅读了每一页。
We didn't see any mention of school diversity.
我们没有看到任何提及学校多样性。
So you're flipping through what? 100 pages, hundreds of pages?
所以你在翻阅什么？100页，几百页？
That's right, and all of these various grants, and you read the fine lines in these various grants, and we didn't find it. I felt-- I felt I was punched in the gut, and I lost my breath.
没错，所有这些各种各样的拨款，你读这些各种各样拨款的细则，我们没有找到它。我感到——我感到我被腹部猛击了，我喘不过气来。
You were sitting, reading the Federal Register?
你当时坐着，阅读《联邦公报》？
Yes.
是的。
And you really had thought there would be.
而且你真的以为会有的。
That is correct. And I particularly thought that there would be because, again, in the big conference room, at DoD, Maryland Avenue, as it's called here in Washington DC, with the top deputies and the chief himself, Duncan, hearing that the Obama administration was committed to research-based policies. And here we are, pointing to all of the scholarly articles and journals showing the positive benefits of school integration, and yet the administration initially ignored them.
那确实正确。而且我特别认为会有，因为，再次，在华盛顿特区马里兰大道的国防部（DoD）的大会议室里，在顶级副手和负责人邓肯本人面前，听到奥巴马政府致力于基于研究的政策。而在这里，我们指出了所有显示学校整合积极好处的学术文章和期刊，然而政府最初却忽视了它们。
NIKOLE HANNAH JONES: So we asked Secretary Duncan why. That's actually a question I've been wanting to ask him for a couple of years now. And he said that they didn't include it because it's too toxic.
尼可·汉纳·琼斯：所以我们问了邓肯部长为什么。那实际上是我几年来一直想问他的一个问题。他说他们没有包括它，因为它太有毒了。
I think it would have been very difficult to get that through Congress at that point. Congress had to approve this, and there are other tools to try and get at this.
我认为在那个时候通过国会会非常困难。国会必须批准这个，还有其他工具可以尝试达到这一点。
It just seemed like such a perfect place to put it in. You could have just snuck it in. You wouldn't even have had to call it integration. It could have been money for magnet schools.
它看起来就像一个放入它的完美地方。你本可以偷偷放入它。你甚至不必称它为整合。它可能是磁力学校的钱。
You can't sneak things in. That's not how Congress works. And you have to be very clear on this. And the chances of Congress approving something like that, sadly, we thought we were like basically none.
你不能偷偷放入东西。国会运作不是那样。而且你必须对此非常清楚。而国会批准像那样东西的机会，悲哀的是，我们认为基本上是零。
NIKOLE HANNAH JONES: OK, but are you saying that it would have been impossible to get Congress to approve something that just simply gave districts an incentive to increase diversity, that was not forcing anything? Is that what you're saying?
尼可·汉纳·琼斯：好的，但你是说，国会不可能批准一个仅仅给予各区增加多样性激励、并不强迫任何事情的东西吗？那是你在说的吗？
Well, we thought it would have been very, very difficult with Congress. And again, we thought there are other strategies, other vehicles to get at this.
嗯，我们认为在国会会非常、非常困难。而且再次，我们认为有其他策略，其他载体来达到这一点。
So when he's talking about other strategies, he means they are promoting integration through other means, through visiting places that are promoting integration, through helping districts figure out how to understand court rulings on integration if they want to do integration to encourage that. But he also said, "Those students, who you're worried about in segregated schools, we're doing a ton of stuff to help those students in particular. We've put 5 billion extra dollars into schools that are the lowest performing schools. Those tend to be high poverty segregated schools. We're trying to focus on improving teachers in those schools, improving quality in those schools."
所以当他在谈论其他策略时，他的意思是他们正在通过其他方式促进整合，通过访问促进整合的地方，通过帮助各区弄清楚如果他们想整合以鼓励它，如何理解关于整合的法院裁决。但他也说，“那些你担心的在种族隔离学校里的学生，我们正在做大量工作来特别帮助那些学生。我们在表现最差的学校里投入了50亿美元额外资金。那些往往是高贫困种族隔离学校。我们正试图专注于改善那些学校的教师，改善那些学校的质量。”
We do have some high poverty schools now where you have 90% graduation rates, 95% graduation rates, and 90% of those are going on to college. Now, we do not have enough. We have a long way to go. There are many places where there are huge inequities in resources, and federal money can't begin to make up for the fact that so much of public schools is locally funded by property taxes, which is inherently in many places unfair and unequal, and I would say un-American.
我们现在确实有一些高贫困学校，那里的毕业率是90%，95%，而且其中90%都在上大学。现在，我们还没有足够多。我们还有很长的路要走。有许多地方资源存在巨大不平等，而联邦资金无法弥补公立学校这么多是由当地财产税资助的这一事实，这在许多地方本质上是不公平和不平等的，我会说是非美国的。
But you've seen massive influxes of literally a couple million dollars per school in many of these places that have led to more teachers, and more social workers, and more after-school programming, and lower class size, and that's why you're getting better results.
但你在许多这些地方看到过每所学校字面上的数百万美元的巨额流入，这导致了更多的教师、更多的社会工作者、更多的课后编程和更小的班级规模，这就是你得到更好结果的原因。
Nikole, you've reported on this for years. What do you think of that?
尼可，你报道这个多年了。你对此有什么看法？
NIKOLE HANNAH JONES: What I think when Secretary Duncan is saying that the administration is going to focus on bringing those segregated schools up to par, then what that's saying is the administration is going to try to make separate schools equal. And separate but equal is the doctrine of the Supreme Court in the 1800s that Brown v Board of Education struck down.
尼可·汉纳·琼斯：当邓肯部长说政府将专注于将那些种族隔离学校提高到标准水平时，我所想的是，这说明政府将试图使隔离学校平等。而隔离但平等（separate but equal）是1800年代最高法院的原则，布朗诉教育委员会案（Brown v Board of Education）推翻了它。
When you asked the Secretary if he saw it as separate but equal, did he agree?
当你问部长他是否认为这是隔离但平等时，他同意吗？
NIKOLE HANNAH JONES: He didn't see it that way at all. But if you just listen to the words which are saying, "We are not focusing on breaking up that segregation, we are focusing on bringing those schools up to par," I don't know what other interpretation we can have of that. And these same conversations that we're having today, we've had 10 years ago, 20 years ago, which is that we will make segregated schools equal to white schools. And we have not done it.
尼可·汉纳·琼斯：他根本没有那样看。但如果你只是听那些话，意思是，“我们没有专注于打破那种隔离，我们专注于将那些学校提高到标准水平”，我不知道我们还能有什么其他的解释。而我们今天正在进行的这些同样的对话，我们10年前、20年前就进行过，即我们将使种族隔离学校等于白人学校。而我们还没有做到。
So I don't I don't know how, after all of these years, after all of these different reforms, and we have yet to be able to do it, how we continue to say that we will be able to. The evidence is not there.
所以我不知道，在这些年之后，在所有这些不同的改革之后，我们还有待能够做到它，我们怎么还能继续说我们有能力做到。证据并不存在。
I think there's another reason why they focus on this strategy in particular. And I think it's partially just that this approach feels better.
我认为他们特别关注这个策略还有另一个原因。而且我认为部分原因只是这种方法感觉更好。
You mean, fixing segregated schools versus integrating schools?
你的意思是，修复种族隔离学校与整合学校？
Versus integrating schools, because integrating schools, the very conceit of integrating schools is that you have to pay attention to race, and you have to acknowledge that you have a problem with racism. And it it's more comfortable to say that it's not an issue about racism. It's just an issue about high poverty schools that need help, and need more money, and need more resources.
与整合学校相比，因为整合学校，整合学校的真正构思是你必须关注种族，你必须承认你有一个关于种族主义的问题。而且说这不是一个关于种族主义的问题更舒服。它只是一个需要帮助、需要更多钱、需要更多资源的高贫困学校的问题。
NIKOLE HANNAH JONES: It's just resources, not race.
尼可·汉纳·琼斯：它只是资源，不是种族。
Yeah, we like the idea that this is not a race issue.
是的，我们喜欢这不是一个种族问题的想法。
Yeah, or white people like the idea that it's not a race issue.
是的，或者白人喜欢它不是一个种族问题的想法。
Right. By "we," I'm mean I'm talking for my people.
没错。用“我们”，我是指我是在代表我的人民说话。
Yeah, and mine.
是的，还有我的。
[SNICKERING]
[窃笑]
NIKOLE HANNAH JONES: That's the end right there. That was the end.
尼可·汉纳·琼斯：那就在那里结束了。那就在那里。
Our program was produced today by Nancy Updike and Chana Joffe-Walt, with Zoe Chace, Sean Cole, Stephanie Foo, Miki Meek, Jonathan Menjivar, Brian Reed, Robyn Semien, Melissa Shipp. Julie Snyder is our editorial consultant. Other editing help this week from Neil Drumming. Production help from Billy Sullivan. Seth Lind's out operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Elna Baker scouts stories for the show. Kimberly Henderson is her office coordinator.
我们今天的节目由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和莎娜·乔菲-沃尔特制作，佐伊·切斯（Zoe Chace）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、斯蒂芬妮·傅（Stephanie Foo）、米基·米克（Miki Meek）、乔纳森·门吉瓦尔（Jonathan Menjivar）、布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、梅丽莎·希普（Melissa Shipp）协助。朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）是我们的编辑顾问。本周其他编辑帮助来自尼尔·德鲁明（Neil Drumming）。制作帮助来自比利·沙利文（Billy Sullivan）。赛斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。爱丽丝·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的办公室经理。埃尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）为节目搜寻故事。金伯利·亨德森（Kimberly Henderson）是她的办公室协调员。
Music help from Damian Graf, from Rob Geddis. Special thanks today to [? Navaet ?] Shalom, Susan Eden, Phil Tegler, Richard Kahlenberg, Jane Holt, Marian [? Walz, ?] Dana Goldstein, the Martha's Vineyard Hebrew Center, Sarah Garland, Julian [? Juman, ?] and Jack Daugherty.
音乐帮助来自达米安·格拉夫（Damian Graf）、罗伯·格迪斯（Rob Geddis）。今天特别感谢[? Navaet ?] Shalom、苏珊·伊甸、菲尔·泰格勒（Phil Tegler）、理查德·卡伦伯格（Richard Kahlenberg）、简·霍尔特（Jane Holt）、玛丽安 [? Walz ?]、达娜·戈德斯坦（Dana Goldstein）、玛莎葡萄园希伯来中心（Martha's Vineyard Hebrew Center）、萨拉·加兰德（Sarah Garland）、朱利安 [? Juman ?] 和杰克·多尔蒂（Jack Daugherty）。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. The American Life is delivered to public radio station by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks as always to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who says the best way to find out what sunblock is right for you is word of mouth.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由PRX，公共广播交易所（Public Radio Exchange）发送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，他说找出哪种防晒霜适合你的最好方法是口碑相传。
Neighbor to neighbor, white person to white person.
邻里对邻里，白人对白人。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week, with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周回来，带着更多《美国生活》的故事。